MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
for coming out today
during this wonderful
[INAUDIBLE] week.
Both part of this fall's
lineup at the NYU Skirball
Center for the Performing
Arts, the Heidi Latsky Dance
and Pilobolus, are here
to perform for you today.
And to start us off we have
two performers from Pilobolus
who are doing an excerpt
from their show Shadowland.
Pilobolus will be performing
the full North American
premiere of the full event for
three weeks from November 20
to December 6.
And they're actually
going to perform it twice
today because they want you
all to sit in the center
section for the beginning
so you can see the shadows,
and then we're going to
shift everybody to the sides
so you can then see how they
do it behind the scenes.
And they'll do the
whole thing again.
It's only a few
minutes, so it's not
going to be doing a great long
performance for you twice.
It is great, though.
So yes, please welcome
Heather and Nate.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: All right, now
everybody move to the sides
and you'll get to see this from
a completely different angle,
which I think is
really interesting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Next up, in
honor of the 25th anniversary
of the Americans with
Disabilities Act, Heidi Latsky
dance will perform
an evening of dance
featuring diverse
unconventional performers
on Sunday, November 15.
Now please welcome
Alexandria, Saki, Jillian,
Jerron, and Meredith.
[MUSIC  PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Another
round of applause.
Yay.
All right.
So both of your dance troupes
are part of the NYU Skirball
Center for the Performing Arts.
The season for 2015 here.
So the Center for
the Performing Arts
is a premier venue
for the presentation
of cultural and
performing arts events
down at New York University
in lower Manhattan.
So the Skirball mission
is to showcase and support
diverse and eclectic talent
from around the world, which
both of you guys and your
dance troupes obviously do.
And it cultivates audiences
for live performance
through deeper
engagement opportunities.
So the Skirball lineup
has theatre, film, dance,
and dialogue.
First of all, you two
introduce yourselves, but then
tell us how your various
troupes became involved
with the Skirball Center.
HEIDI LATSKY: I'm Heidi Latsky.
I've been talking to
Michael Harrington, who's
the producer there,
and we were going
to do something this season.
And then he actually wanted to
push the company back a year,
so we were going to
do it next season.
And I called him up,
and I said, you know,
it's the 25th
anniversary of the ADA,
so 2015 would be
such a good year
to celebrate diversity
and inclusion.
MALE SPEAKER: ADA
is the Americans--
HEIDI LATSKY: The Americans
with Disabilities Act,
which you talked about before.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
HEIDI LATSKY: What's
interesting is
there's a beautiful dance
company out west called Axis,
and they've been around
a really long time doing
physically integrated work.
And so he put the two companies
together for this program.
So I think it's really
remarkable, actually.
ITAMAR KUBOVY: Hi,
I'm Itamar Kubovy.
I'm the executive
producer of Pilobolus.
Our relationship
with Skirball really
had to do initially with
looking to bring the show
Shadowland to New
York, and wanting
to find the perfect place
to do it, which we did.
And Michael, and the rest
of the team at Skirball,
and we got together about
six, eight months ago
and talked about
what we might do,
and decided that this
was the right way
to bring the show into New York.
It's been performing for the
last chunk of time in Europe
and in Asia, and has never been
done in North America before.
So it's super exciting for
us to bring the show home
after having it seen by
so many people that are
our same sort of home audience.
MALE SPEAKER: So was
it developed here
or was it developed
overseas, Shadowland?
ITAMAR KUBOVY: Shadowland
was developed here.
It had a sort of
funny beginning.
We were asked to make a
commercial-- a television
commercial-- for a Hyundai car.
And the request
came in that said,
could you guys make a car
commercial with no car in it?
And we thought, OK, we'll try
to put a light behind a shower
curtain and see what happens.
And it turned out that
we were able to create
a convincing sort
of transformation
of this car in this commercial.
And then we got a
call from the Oscars
shortly after that
saying, could you
do the same for the movies
that were nominated this year?
And suddenly we realized that
this weird advertising inquiry
turned into an enormously
intense creative project.
MALE SPEAKER: How
long ago was this?
ITAMAR KUBOVY: This was
about six years ago,
the first commercial.
And that was the time that
we sort of rediscovered
this kind of modern form
of shadow theater, which
of course has existed forever.
But this was a way of combining
full bodies and this kind
of mixture of graphic and very
plastic work, where you're
seeing the bodies,
but you're also
seeing the images that these
bodies can merge to create.
It's like that very
rare moment where
you stumble into something
and you, go wait a minute.
This is not just a piece,
this is not just an idea,
it's actually sort
of a form that you
can work in for a long time.
And so it doesn't happen
very often that you
bump into something like that.
It's been very
exciting to work in.
MALE SPEAKER: So is
this kind of something
that has just
fallen in your lap,
as you said, but taken you to
a new level of recognition?
Because performing
on the Oscars, right?
And you've done a collaboration
with Penn and Teller,
I believe, and
some other people.
So is this, sort of, breathed
new life into the program,
or is this something--
ITAMAR KUBOVY: Yes.
The answer is yes.
MALE SPEAKER: My question
is, how does this
compare to your
traditional dance theater
that you've always
been doing ongoing?
ITAMAR KUBOVY: You
know, it's interesting,
because in some sense
it's completely different
because it's obviously making
shadows behind a screen
and doing some of the
stuff that you saw.
But in other ways, the
company for 44 years
has been committed to mixing
bodies together and move
from inanimate to
animate-type objects that are
sort of merged and separated.
So you see something
that looks suddenly
like a creature that exists,
that's made out of five people.
And then they all come
apart, and now you
see each individuated
form as a human being.
And so in some sense,
the big theme--
the big idea-- has stayed
consistent all along,
but the manifestation,
or the application,
of the idea to a medium, or
a form, that's brand new.
And certainly has been
accessible to a brand
new audience around
the world in a way
that modern dance isn't
always necessarily accessible
to as broad an audience.
So its brought a lot of
new people to see us.
MALE SPEAKER: So Heidi, you
and your wonderful dancers
as well, you guys are still
more of the traditional--
I say "traditional"
modern dance,
but yet you've
incorporated-- obviously
there is Alexandria at
the end who is deaf.
We have a dancer who
is deaf, and then
other people in your
troupe have disabilities.
Is that bringing the
future into the present,
or would you call that bringing
the past into the present?
HEIDI LATSKY: That's
a hard question.
We were just talking about this.
I would say we're very
nontraditional, even
in the traditional mode, like
what you're talking about.
And actually, we've
been exploring
less traditional ways of opening
this company to the public.
Like we're doing these movement
installations, one of which
we're going to do at Skirball.
We just did one in the
atrium at Lincoln Center.
Also I made a film last year.
I was commissioned by
Montclair State University,
and so we're trying
to expand out.
Because in our case anyway,
that's our initiative.
Because we are a nontraditional
cast, and our mission
is to redefine beauty, and
virtuosity, and also dance.
We just keep trying to find
those venues to promote
the work that we're doing.
Because oftentimes,
especially in the dance world,
you tell people you
have an integrated cast,
or some people
with disabilities,
nontraditional,
unconventional dancers,
and they shy away from it.
MALE SPEAKER: Really?
HEIDI LATSKY: Yes.
Wouldn't you say?
MALE SPEAKER: So what
are the critics--
HEIDI LATSKY: If
you tell somebody
you're a physically
integrated company,
most people call it
"mixed ability" company,
which we can't stand,
because it infers
that there are
different abilities,
which we know that's not true.
But normally, people
would associate a company
like this with people
who are wheelchair users.
That's an automatic assumption,
which as you can see,
that's not the case.
Not that we don't work
with wheelchair users,
we do, but it's not
always the case.
You were going to say something.
MALE SPEAKER: I don't remember
what I was going to say.
HEIDI LATSKY: Did I cut you off?
MALE SPEAKER: No, no.
We're here to hear you talk.
HEIDI LATSKY: I will say
it's been a great year for us
because we have these
presenters now like Skirball.
Like Michael Harrington
inviting us to do Skirball.
Or being at Montclair State, or
at the American Dance Festival,
which are more
traditional venues.
And so it feels like
we're breaking through.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so I want
to actually get over here
to the dancers and let
some of you folks talk.
Will you mind
going down the line
and introducing
yourselves as well?
NATE BUCHSBAUM: I'm Nate.
HEATHER FAVRETTO:
I'm Heather Favretto.
JERRON HERMAN: Herman.
SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETER:
I'm Alexandria Wailes.
JILLIAN HOLLIS:
I'm Jillian Hollis.
MEREDITH FAGES: Meredith Fages.
SAKI MASUDA: Saki Masuda.
XIMENA BORGES:
I'm Ximena Borges,
and I'm the composer for
Heidi Latsky's piece.
And music director.
MALE SPEAKER: And
music director, yes.
So the collaborative process.
I want to talk about
the collaboration
between the dancers and
the executive directors
and the choreographers.
When you guys are coming
up with new material,
especially the both of you
have such unique, I guess, set
of skills is not
what I want to say.
It's like the shadow
theatre is so unique,
and having individuals living
with disabilities is unique
in itself, that you've got
a very popular dance troupe.
So when it comes to
the collaboration,
coming up with new pieces, do
both of you start with an idea
and fit into the dancers,
or work with the dancers
and fit it to the idea?
ITAMAR KUBOVY: I
think when people
make things, they-- my
experience has been we
collaborate with a lot of
people in diverse disciplines
that aren't dance.
We worked a lot with MIT in
their robotics department,
and we worked a lot with
puppeteers and magicians.
We did a piece with Penn
and Teller recently.
And what you realize
by seeing how
all people from all sorts
of disciplines create,
you realize that whether
they're engineers,
or whether they're dancers,
the process of making something
is reasonably similar
across the board.
And it has to do with a
process that's iterative.
And that you start with
where you know, and you
keep chipping away at what you
don't know until you realize
that you've gotten somewhere.
So in a way, we're
constantly working both
of those ends of that question.
You can't tell a story that you
can't make interesting images
for in shadow.
You can't do that.
And at the same
time, you don't know
what images to make until
you've got a story in mind
or an idea in mind.
And so we're always telling
each other the same story over,
and over, and over again
as we chip it forward
until we finally have something
that starts making sense
to everybody.
I don't know if
that explains it,
but it really does go
from both directions.
MALE SPEAKER: In an
artistic way, yes,
I think it perfectly
explains it.
ITAMAR KUBOVY: In my case, when
I started my company in 2001,
I was the material.
So that all the material,
all the choreography,
started from my body.
And sometimes it still does.
And actually in Somewhere we
did take a phrase of mine.
But when I started
in 2006 working
with people with disabilities,
it became clear to me
that that was just
not going to work.
And it wasn't even
interesting to go that way.
And so even though
with the material might
start with my body, it always
evolved with every dancer
I've worked with.
And my interest has always been
in seeing where they take it,
and then making it
better because it's
somebody else's interpretation.
My process really
changed a lot in 2006
because I couldn't
do that anymore.
And then I'm just not interested
in that anymore, to be honest.
In Somewhere we used
a phrase of mine,
but then it just went
all over the place.
And I do want to
talk about the score
because this was a really
intense collaboration
between me and Ximena.
And I actually think you
should talk about it.
You OK with that?
XIMENA BORGES: Well this piece
had a difference score, which
is what made it even harder.
Because we were
starting with a piece
that had already been
created for different music,
and everybody, the dancers, were
used to the different music.
So already starting
to change that
was very difficult to
adjust for everyone.
Right?
And also because the mood
that Heidi wanted to create
was so opposite what
the other score was.
The other score was about
eight or 10 versions
of the song Somewhere
Over the Rainbow.
HEIDI LATSKY: That's
quite the task, right?
Taking Somewhere
Over the Rainbow
and then creating something.
XIMENA BORGES: And then
also I compose music
with only my voice,
and Heidi kept
wanting for it to not
sound like anything.
So anything that I did
that was percussive,
that was like
[PERCUSSIVE NOISES] she's like,
it sounds like you're saying
this, or you're saying that.
So I was totally stuck because
I'm like, well, it's my voice,
so it's always going to sound
like I'm saying something.
So I had to transform
my voice with effects
to such degree where you
couldn't recognize it,
except for maybe
one part where you
recognize me saying ha ha ha.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, so
what we just heard
was all coming out
of your throat?
XIMENA BORGES: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
HEIDI LATSKY: Incredible, right?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, right?
AUDIENCE: Can you do it again?
MALE SPEAKER: Can you
do it again, he asked.
XIMENA BORGES: I can't do
it all at the same time.
There's a million
layers in there.
So the processes
was very difficult
because we are all so
used to this other score.
And it just took a
long time for all of us
to get used to it
because we realized
that even if the
music on its own
worked, if the dancers weren't
really comfortable with it,
and settled into this new
music, and into this new feel
for the piece, the
music didn't work.
So it had to come
from both sides, where
the music had to be something
and then the dancers had
to be part of that too
so that together it would
be what Heidi wanted it to be.
MALE SPEAKER: Huh.
So are any of you guys dancers
for these troupes full-time,
or do you all have-- yes?
Yeah?
You're full time?
OK.
So for the Pilobolus,
Nate and Heather,
you guys have traveled all over
the world with the show, yeah?
HEATHER FAVRETTO: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah?
NATE BUCHSBAUM: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: I mean, what
kind of life is that like?
Do you guys enjoy this?
Do you go home at the end
of the day, you're like,
I love my shadow performing.
It's so great.
HEATHER FAVRETTO: Yes.
Oh my gosh, we have the
best job in the world.
No, we've spent a lot of time
in Germany, and in Europe.
And we've been lucky enough, we
had a great tour in Australia
last summer, and been
down in Brazil and Chile.
And it's really cool to see how
audiences respond to this work
everywhere.
Some places the audience
is filled with children,
some places it's mostly adults.
And just the way that we can
animate ourselves to be larger
than life in shadow, and
how impactful that is,
and how people can relate
to this weird animal girl
character.
MALE SPEAKER: How long have
you been doing the animal?
HEATHER FAVRETTO: 3 1/2 years.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh wow.
HEATHER FAVRETTO: Yeah.
But it's cool.
It's great.
I mean, we miss our
families, but we've kind of
created a family on the road.
Christmases together,
Thanksgivings.
MALE SPEAKER: How big
is the whole troupe?
HEATHER FAVRETTO: The
cast is nine dancers.
And when we go a long
tour we travel with 12.
And uniquely, all of us
know two or three roles,
so we rotate in case
people get injured.
Since we're
traveling, people want
a day off to see Munich, or
London, or wherever we are.
So it works out
really cool that way.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, that's neat.
The rest of you haven't
introduced yourselves yet.
Come on, let's hear it.
JILLIAN HOLLIS: So I've been
dancing with Heidi since 2002,
a year after the
company started.
So a very long time.
And I've been able to see
the company grow and expand
to where it is now
is kind of amazing.
And we've had a really
great year of steady work.
Most of us dance
for other groups,
but this is my priority.
But I do, like, Cabaret Life,
and I'm a Pilates teacher,
so I'm full-time
committed to Heidi
and we rehearse three times a
week when we are in session,
I guess.
When we have something
that we're working towards.
MALE SPEAKER: How
often does that happen?
Do you go into rehearsals
on a set schedule
every couple months?
JILLIAN HOLLIS: We
have a set schedule.
So usually we have a time
frame, Monday, Wednesday,
Friday, that we
are committed to.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool
So we actually
have two microphones in
the aisles if any of you
have questions for
anybody up here.
To Alexandria
specifically here, I
guess what made you decide
to want to start dancing
in the first place?
SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER: I started
dancing when I was around two.
It was just in my
lifeblood growing up.
I went to college at
University of the Arts.
I have a bachelor's
degree in dance.
And then after college I
was trying to find myself,
and then I got more
involved with acting,
and really immersed in acting
on Broadway, and TV, and film.
But dance was always in
my soul and something
I really wanted to
pursue, but I didn't
have as many opportunities
until I met Heidi and I started
working with them in 2013.
And I was one of the new
members at that time.
I was really enjoying being
involved with that company.
The constant
exploration of stillness
at the same time
exploring virtuosity
and whatever that might mean.
But I'm always feeling
that I'm being challenged
in the best sense possible.
You see something and Heidi
really pushes us to keep going
and explore that even further.
So that's something I really
enjoy, that stimulation.
And when I'm not dancing,
and when I'm not in a show,
if I'm not rehearsing, I'm
actually a museum educator.
And I work for four different
museums here around the city.
Doing freelance.
HEIDI LATSKY: Tell what's
she doing now though.
MALE SPEAKER: And so what
else are you doing now?
You're an understudy, correct?
SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETER: Yes.
So I'm actually involved as
the associate choreographer
for the Broadway
show Spring Awakening
that's on Broadway right now.
And I'm also an understudy
for Marlee Matlin
in that performance.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So what are
the biggest challenges
for you learning a new piece?
If you can't hear the music
like the rest of the cast,
how do you keep the time,
and what cues do you use?
SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETER:
Well, with rehearsal.
You know, that's what
rehearsals are for.
Generally it's not just
for learning the movements.
You have muscle memory that
can really help with that.
And I think that musicality,
anyone has musicality.
We all have that.
It really depends on how much
musicality one might have,
is regardless of whether or
not you're deaf or hearing.
I have a lot of hearing
friends who can't move,
who can't dance, who can't sing.
I'm thinking, gee, you
know, you're hearing,
you must automatically
be able to do
certain things that rely
on your hearing, which
isn't really true.
And so in terms of music,
it's very strong vibrations,
frequency.
You can feel these elements
in the environment.
And I think I just
happened to be maybe more
aware on a whole body level.
There are some notes that are
higher I might not necessarily
be able to feel them, but I
rely on visual cues as well.
I memorize the pieces, I
memorized the movement,
so I know it's my turn.
I am attuned to the lighting,
how that lighting changes,
and that's also a cue.
And the other dancers around me.
And rehearsal.
I mean, really that's
a strong element of it.
It's part of that
process for any of us.
MALE SPEAKER: That's amazing.
Question over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi, this is
[INAUDIBLE] performance.
I'm an attest to your comment.
As much as I enjoy music,
I'm zero talent singing.
It just doesn't work that way.
But I have question for the
performers with disabilities.
This is going to be a
very Google-y question.
We have a lot of conversations
about, for example,
women at tech.
Since they're minorities,
how are they going to evolve?
How are they going to lead?
How are they going to overcome
the problems for other women
to come up?
So you as professional
performers,
do you feel that you
have that obligation
to not only bring
yourself up, but also
pave the way for other talented
performers such as yourself
to have a chance to be
able to show what they have
and what they can bring?
Like the beautiful pieces
you guys performed.
I've never seen
anything like that.
And I'm a better person
just seeing that.
So do you feel that
obligation, or do you feel just
you have to focus on
being a success story,
and then everything
else falls in place?
JERRON HERMAN: I think
I have a response,
because I was invited to dance.
I came to the city to write the
next great American musical,
which is still going to happen.
I hadn't thought of dance.
It was on my radar.
And so when I was
invited to meet Heidi
from another
choreographer, and just
to kind of serendipitous
path that I was on,
I saw an opportunity that
wasn't first given to me.
I think a lot of
my creative outlet
was because it wasn't in
the vanguard for me to dance
or for me you have
a visible performer,
so I relegated myself
to the background.
However, now I do feel a
great sense of pride first,
and ability first, and
then a sense of obligation.
My goal now is for my
type to be saturated
in the airwaves
and the atmosphere
because it's so underdeveloped,
or underrepresented.
So I do feel that sense.
And as a person of
color too, I think
there's this compounded view of
that because I know that there
aren't a lot of African American
people with disabilities on TV
as well.
So there's, like,
this other thing.
But that is all
to say that I find
the company to be a
great playground for all
of my questions.
I grew up not really
in my community.
And so it's really
great that I'm
now in the disability
community and taking
a really active role.
Because it is part of me.
SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER: And I also, I
don't think that it's
an obligation, per se.
Not even a duty, necessarily.
But I just still feel
it's part of the journey.
I do feel that it is
important to prove
that not only to yourself,
but also to society,
and increase the visibility
and encourage opening
the door for other people.
There is definitely
a lot of talent
that's not being recognized
and being encouraged.
It's not just one
person who's obligated.
It does take everyone
to be involved.
So I feel like all
of these people
here, when people witness
and watch our show,
they're seeing both disability
and non-disabled people working
together.
And there's a
bigger vision here.
And that really shows
what's possible.
Flexibility.
A lot people sometimes are
not sure what to do with you.
What to do with me.
They'll think that's
a disabled person.
But there's so many different
ways to make it work.
And it's not that big of a deal.
So you just have to honor
what needs to happen
as being part of the process.
But other than that,
you just go with it.
And I've noticed that
has been really powerful.
People really respond to
that process, the visibility.
And I agree with
Jerron is saying
in terms of artists
of color as well,
to increase that visibility.
And as a woman as well.
So that's sort of a
triple whammy there.
So yes, we do feel sometimes
like we want to just sort of,
why bother, you know, and
give up and throw our arms
up in the air sometimes, because
it can be really frustrating.
But to recognize
that we are making
strides in increasing
visibility,
and it's a moment
by moment change.
Like Heidi said, for the
company it's been a great year,
and also for me too, it's
been an excellent year.
I've just been very,
very busy as an artist.
I've gone through some long
dry spells of lots of auditions
and not having very much
going on for myself,
so you just have to
kind of roll with it.
That's part of the
business in general,
and that's applicable to anyone.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
MALE SPEAKER: So how
would you recommend
that we spread the word?
I mean, do you have
educational opportunities?
Do you have volunteer
opportunities?
How do we get involved?
How do we let other people know?
HEIDI LATSKY: More specific?
MALE SPEAKER: If I wanted to
get involved and help raise
awareness for either
of your troupes, or do
you have classes that you
teach when people want
to get involved in dancing.
If someone may
have disabilities,
if they don't know where
to start, where do they go?
HEIDI LATSKY: I don't
teach on a regular basis,
although we are starting--
the DOE is very interested now
in getting us into the schools.
MALE SPEAKER: Public schools?
HEIDI LATSKY:
Public schools, yes.
So Jerron is teaching
there right now, actually,
in one school.
And we're working
on a whole workshop
to maybe be an
annual thing, or just
to get this work into
the schools, which
I think is desperately needed.
We have a website, people
can contact us at any time.
We don't have a school but
we're always rehearsal,
and we're actually
always looking
for performers and for people
to support our movement,
because I do feel
like it's a movement.
When you're asking the
people with disabilities
I feel like this company, and
me specifically, since 2006
I've become more and
more of an advocate.
And I wouldn't say it's as
an advocate for disability,
but it's really for-- we coined
it-- the beauty of difference,
right?
The beauty of the individual.
And that's really become
very important to us all.
So we encourage
people, we welcome
people to become
part of the process,
support us in this mission.
MALE SPEAKER: Does
Pilobolus, you guys
have-- you guys teach
workshops, right?
ITAMAR KUBOVY: We teach
quite a bit, yeah.
And I think we actually have a
program on the road as we tour,
and in Connecticut,
where our studio is
during the summers,
where we essentially
look for non-dancers and put
them together with dancers
in a creative process workshop.
And we work with
multi-generational groups,
and people who have
very little ability
to do acrobatics, but
then have a huge ability
to do all sorts of other
things that mixed together
with difference allows for
great things to happen.
So we do that in the summer.
And all the information
there is also on our website.
And the Ford Foundation
has been supporting us
over the last couple of years
to bring that programming
to different cities where
we're going to perform.
And around the country in the
US, we show up in a week early
and then reach out to a whole
bunch of different groups,
and sort of introduce them
to give them a, sort of,
an immersive sense in what
it is that we do and we do a.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Question over here.
AUDIENCE: That was
really fascinating.
I didn't read the fine
print of the announcement,
and so I didn't realize
until you got up here
that it was troupe
with disabilities.
That was a really
interesting experience.
And I guess also
my wife is deaf,
I know a tiny, tiny
bit of sign language.
Not very good about that.
But I did pick up
some of that, and I
was curious what was being
said there in the performance.
SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETER:
So I'm talking to Garret
and I was wondering if he
understood what I was saying.
And I was actually
signing the lyrics
to Somewhere Over the Rainbow.
Yeah, but actually
understand the process
was that when Heidi and I
collaborate, and we were
discussing it,
she asked me to do
an ASL translation of the song.
And then I went back to
the beginning of the lyrics
and I was creating, an
accumulation of the vocabulary.
So this is first, and then
second, and then third.
And so I was sort of
accumulating the vocabulary,
and then I was just
turning up to speed.
So from the beginning
to the very end
I was signing the
lyrics of the song.
And I was incorporating
the movement as well.
MALE SPEAKER: OK good.
I don't feel bad about
not recognizing it.
SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETER:
No, it's totally fine.
It's totally fine.
HEIDI LATSKY: Another
reason that you probably
didn't get it is that
I took her face away.
And I didn't know that.
So at the first rehearsal
when I said to Alexandria,
can you sign it?
Just be neutral in your face.
And that's like taking a
whole chunk of the language
out of the language, right?
Which I didn't realize
until that experience,
but I didn't want this
section of dancing
to just be her signing.
I really wanted it to be a lot
more internal and evocative.
Now I know how challenging
that was for Alexandria.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
That's wonderful.
So we're actually
running short on time
here, so I want to thank you
guys again for coming out.
And give the final plug here.
This Skirball Center is located
at the base of NYU's Kimmel
Center for University Life.
The main entrance at
566 LaGuardia Place,
New York, New York.
NYUskirball.org.
For more info
heidilatskydance.com.
You will be there
to November 15.
Pilobolus.org, you will be there
November 20 through December 6.
Everybody, thank you
so much for coming out.
This has been wonderful.